tonight a big win for Trump endorse
candidates all across the country also
tonight Virginia governor Glenn Younkin
he's going to join us uh with an update
on his fight against radical socialist
Democrats that want to indoctrinate your
kids and later all across the country in
California we have a school district now
in San Diego reportedly promoting
extremely I mean extremely graphic
sexual content gender Theory from you
know first through 12th grade this is by
far the worst I've ever heard it about
it we have a shocking new report but
we'll give you a viewer warning right
now you're not going to want your kids
to watch that segment but first I
present to you the leader of the Free
World pictured right there wearing a
mask at his desk by himself trying
really hard not to transmit covet over
the telephone Biden went on to
participate virtually in a meeting and
it went about as well as you probably
would imagine with Joe Biden take a look
I stopped there and turn this over to
the vice president there's so much more
to say but I'm anxious to hear from all
of you thank you thank you thank you do
I sign this order now
I'm going to sign this executive order
right now okay I wish I were with you in
person quite frankly but I'm getting
there
you're on mute I can't hear you
we feel your presence Mr President
thank you
am I the only American that finds this
humiliating embarrassing does anybody at
this point really think Joe Biden is
capable of running for a second term
will he make it another two years now
last night during a Democratic primary
debate in New York City well two current
uh Camp two current congressmen one
Congressman one congresswoman Jerry
Nadler Carolyn Maloney were willing to
endorse uh neither were willing to
endorse a Biden reelection bid in fact
congresswoman Maloney said she doesn't
think the Joe could possibly run for
another term take a look at this
should President Biden run again in 2024
yes Mr Nadler too early to say it
doesn't serve the purpose of the
democratic party to to deal with that
until after the midterms Miss Maloney I
don't believe he's running for
reelection
all right so does the congresswoman
Maloney does she know something the rest
of us do not know or is she just stating
the obvious tonight it's almost
impossible to find a single Democrat not
named Jill Biden willing to endorse a
Biden reelection campaign Democratic
lawmakers you know Angie Craig Cory Bush
AOC Tim Ryan Dean Phillips now Nadler
Maloney all snubbing Joe Biden in public
for him it should be humiliating the new
quote inflation reduction act which is a
joke is a blatant last-ditch effort to
salvage what is left of his support from
the Democratic radical base
unfortunately for Joe and the American
people there are two problems with this
Ploy first no level of green energy
spending is ever going to satisfy the
desires of the climate alarmist
religious cult and second the so-called
inflation reduction act actually as we
told you last night increases inflation
in part because of massive tax hikes
especially on the middle class now
Democrats they claim to be the Champions
they have a monopoly of compassion on
low and middle income Americans and
minorities in America but if you look at
the analysis from The non-partisan Joint
Committee on taxation it is the middle
class that are being hit the hardest
with the Mansion uh Schumer bill just
take a look at your screen if you make
it under seventy five thousand dollars a
year you'll be forced to Pony up an
additional 135 billion in taxes and
don't forget the average couple because
of Biden inflation is paying an extra
sixty eight hundred dollars per year
everyone making between 75 and 200 000 a
year they're going to see their taxes go
up by a whopping 151 billion dollars and
that's not all the bill also aims to
raise an additional 200 billion dollars
with the help of 87 new 87 000 new IRS
agents that's more than double of what
we have right now or as the Wall Street
Journal put it the I IRS is about to go
beast mode now these new agents will
conduct a massive new wave of tax audits
in other words many of you will start
getting the Hannity treatment your
yearly audit with a special focus on
small businesses that don't have the
resources to fight back against an
extremely complex Federal audit and when
you think it couldn't get any worse
think again because the spending Bill
also includes a brand new import tax on
crude oil and petroleum-based products
at a time when we have record high gas
prices and on top of that as you know by
now Senator manchin signed off on all of
this West Virginians they will all
suffer as a result Mansion doesn't seem
to mind after all 99 percent of his
individual donors are from out of state
did you know that West Virginia and by
the way before we get to our guests can
we please bury the myth known as middle
class Joe Amtrak Joe Biden take a look
at the chart again middle class Joe
nobody's going to get taxed if you if
you make under 400 000 a year is taking
money from low and middle come Americans
small businesses and he's giving it to
wealthy green energy government
contractors in Washington DC all at a
time when Americans are already being
squeezed by his inflation and his record
high gas prices and of course now by
Rising interest rates and the recession
so Joe Biden does not care about you it
doesn't feel your pain he'll never stand
up to the insane new new green deer deal
energy cabal he just doesn't have the
moral courage I don't even think that he
knows that for example today would be
Wednesday but anyway soon in just over
two years a new person will inhabit the
Oval Office our nation will hopefully
have its National nightmare be over hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compel analysis you will not get it
anywhere else